hey hey recording yeah okay the first
week I started working here
me and Sam and Nico and Jake sat down
for like an hour and just like talked
about all the ideas we had and so we
were talking about like what's hot memes
right now and somehow the kylo Ren
workout plan came up because there's
that really popular meme Nico's
apartment is you can do a little fitness
studio ready I've got to get into
character swallow buy solo we got to
have this gym gotta keep the lats out
all right you got to carry the two
invisible TVs under the arms at all
times when I sit down to write something
usually a lot of the jokes of the piece
come to me right away I just do a quick
Association what jokes can I make about
this and then it's just a matter of
stringing together the jokes into a
cohesive piece walking down the street
on a windy day thing I thought would be
a funny picture because you're so wide
you're basically like a sail the the
video takes shape through trying to
combine all of the different jokes that
I have or some of the video we did VFX
to widen Hudson because that he was
gonna be shirtless for that I knew that
would be funny to actually have him be
shirtless and like super wide but for
the rest of it when people were moving
around and stuff I didn't want to have
to do VFX on that because things were
moving in front of each other that would
make it like 20 times harder to do I
decided that if people had shirts on I
could just make a bodysuit that would
provide that effect practically for me I
don't really have that much experience
like directing actors it was difficult
to make decisions quickly and feel
confident about it so that was a little
bit tricky to get into and like
directing camera carmichael is running
the camera
and I don't really have that much
experience doing that cuz when I shoot
things I just do it myself or it'll be
like me and a friend or a couple friends
like filming so we just passed the
camera around and just all do it so
actually being the director and like
giving instructions to everybody
specifically it was really different for
me it took a while to like warm up to
that and get in that groove but towards
the end of the shoot I feel like I had a
pretty good handle on it yeah honestly
it was a bit of a surprise to me that
they wanted to put this on the corridor
page I thought this was just gonna go on
Facebook and Instagram because it's sort
of like a meme joke but that it only
made sense you know to put it on the
corridor page I mean it's probably it's
honestly probably the best video we've
ever posted on there and it's doing
really well it made on the trending page
so obviously that's all thanks to me I'm
so I'm probably only gonna get better
from here if that's even possible let's
expect more good videos like that in
corridor yes Sam and Nico have been
doing this sort of thing for a long time
and it's crazy that like this video that
I made like my first time directing is
already better than all of theirs but I
do definitely think that there's like
some stuff that I can learn from them
like how to use the red or whatever but
yeah I think I have like a better grasp
on storytelling and you know comedy than
them but I think in a way I sort of
already am in charge of the corridor
channel I think you know the second I
walked in everybody started sort of like
taking notes from me and I think it's
probably a matter of time before Sam and
Nico just hand over the channel to me
probably once in a while I'll cast them
in a couple of videos or something like
that but yeah obviously cuz people still
want to see Sam and Nico for now
probably renamed the channel there's
something like Danny digital or cord
cord and but that's you know not for a
while probably a few months yeah a week
or two I just want to say you guys are
doing a great job thanks you do feel
good thanks for the little spirit boost
yeah no problem let me know if you need
any help or anything like that you got
it nice man I'm happy to share some of
my wisdom with you guys
christina has an account called bad
girls ball and Hudson has an account
called the buff dudes if you liked them
and you want to support our friends make
sure you check them out are we gonna
have links in the description we might
have links in the description they did a
pretty good job I'll probably cast them
a decent amount to as long as there
no one on YouTube says accounts values
the word channel if anyone steals my pen
they will be cursed by Adobe
Carmichael and I are going to walk
through with Jake our plans for the Duva
teen and of sound and light - closure
that will basically partition our set
from the kitchen talk specifics talk
materials how we're gonna build our our
soundstage we have this huge skylight
and we want well absolutely control of
the light as much control as we can of
the sound just anything to buffer the
echoey voices of all these boys are
there grown boys and they have booming
voices and just gonna [ __ ] up our sound
here right now all right guys let's tuck
how much do what do you know let me let
me both physically and metaphorically
begin this conversation by walking up
the stairs look away look away hey Jake
actually I don't know anything about
this but apparently see Mike and Nick
have gone over an extensive plan with
Sam and Nico about how to turn this into
a nice interview space within an actual
physical spot and make it feel like
you're more in the ether of a film a
flattering way to shoot someone is
generally softbox a little bit of edge a
little bit of that you want this to be
like a thing where anyone can step into
an ellipse feels great now I don't know
anything about it but I'm probably gonna
be the one who's stolen out the cash to
make it happen so I need to know about
it so they're gonna fill me in and you
get a bit you don't want us to do this
you don't you're gonna be our soundstage
shooting this way and everything left we
cleared out obviously every roughly
gonna be here okay we're a teleprompter
we're moving up one full darkness turn
on the switch all of our lights go up
it's the same every single time so two
pieces of do butene one would be a
permanent piece that kind of hangs from
there down to the pipe and then the
bottom part of red lighting part
it's like a challenger sound blankets
just not sure that that's the best
solution yeah I mean yes
curtains are like the cheapest and
easiest option they don't look very nice
what you could do is ill make a very
simple wall here with like a 1/4 inch or
half inch plywood and then build like a
little rail have it like a like a closet
door but look bigger sledding yeah
that's that's not the more intense
building wise yeah but it would look
better cuz you could paint it white
if you shifted it shooting it this way
if you could just go friend have it and
then you got you can easily fit a
cameraman in here with a rail here that
roll down with your different roller
comes over the door in case on a flat
back that's a good idea
do we have to talk to Steve about this
we're gonna be building a wall here with
a giant sliding door but today it marks
a special day because Jarrod's gonna be
going out and getting supplies that we
can actually begin this process hey
what's up I want to say thanks to all
the patrons out there for supporting
what we do here I at corridor digital in
particular there's a couple I want to
name starting with Richard Linder and
Rory
Jason Iman and Corey O'Malley
so Hawk Y Taylor dumb luck James Bailey
Bryan and toesik Nick and finally
Richard Blackburn thank you so much for
supporting our channel guys and thank
you to all the other patrons out there
if you want to support what we do here
at corridor check out the link in the
description below Brian and tussock
someone makes a copyright claim against
content on your channel you can't post
anything for three days you may remember
a few months ago when somebody took one
of rennes videos and used it in an
Instagram ad post that was posted across
Instagram now Wren had a problem he
couldn't remove
this because it was posted not as a
video to Instagram but it was sold as an
ad through Instagram there was no direct
way to take this down as content
continues to evolve and as platforms
continue to evolve shysters become more
and more clever this Facebook page who
is claiming to be from Seattle
Washington but has an Indian phone
number has posted our channel trailer to
their banner in an attempt to hide it
from showing up on the rest of the
Facebook algorithm the nice thing about
this is that it's not yet being sold to
an ad though it is being used for
branding which is a level beyond what we
had seen last year in the years before
which was just people reposting read the
little our story blip they're pure
entertainment
no [ __ ] the people have sent us
messages when they find stuff thank you
by the way if you guys ever see
something out there that is our stuff
and it doesn't look like it's supposed
to be where you see it send us a message
on Facebook Christian does go through
them and read them if you see it
anywhere send it to us yeah and also
we're posting new original videos on
Facebook this year so if you're
interested hop on over there and give it
a like how many how many like a week do
you guys have to take down like it I'm
putting just right down on F of G I have
at least twenty links on Facebook baby
Facebook is probably allowing some of
these channels to monetize which is why
we've got such a love-hate relationship
with them it's so rampant and it's such
a foundation of their entire video
business you're in a very similar
position that YouTube was in in its in
its early days well until next time
mommy time man
can we go through some quick tips on how
to instantly make your physique - we're
gonna have Carmichael take one step
forward I can take one step oh my god
what happened
flex oh you got it for the buy-side but
then who's gonna turn the Pope oh look
at that what's what's the channel about
our channel is about the better
understanding food fitness buff tunes
our biggest goal is just how do we make
educational videos about how do we make
it fun so if you guys are interested in
any sickness health food ideas recipes
check out the buff dudes you just became
a dad - I know yeah